Hello everyone. I'm Peter Gernis. I'm a
senior manager on the Trend AI zero day
initiative uh team. We focus on
vulnerability research and we'll be
presenting our zeroday vulnerability
discovery engine that we've used over
the past year.
>> And hi everybody. My name is Derek. I'm
from the same team. I'm a vulnerability
researcher.
So to understand kind of where Fenrirer,
which is our zero day vulnerability
discovery engine, lives, you have to
understand from a conceptual point of
view that we're building a unified
platform that contains both offensive
and defensive components. So this talk
focuses more on the zero day discovery,
but we have a different component called
MIR, which strictly focus on endday
vulnerability research and threat
research.
And what we're accomplishing with this
is a birectional intelligence feedback
loop. So for example, one of the
vulnerabilities we discovered in our
discovered in our zeroday vulnerability
engine is a NVIDIA uh command injection
vulnerability in Isaac group framework
which is a robotics framework. Uh when
we submitted that vulnerability for
triage uh to the NVIDIA team, we
immediately started tracking that as an
endday uh in Mimir's uh repository. When
they released the patch, 23 of our
autonomous langraph agents on Mimir went
out to that advisory page, went out to
that co exact code commit and then
rescan that repo. Fenrir then was able
to take that and then find two more bugs
that they had one introduced and another
was a vulnerability uh patch bypass.
So we believe that the added value in
zeroday vulnerability discovery can come
significantly through traditional endday
vulnerability research.
Uh yes. So I'm going to introduce the
fware pipeline high level. So the idea
is quite simple. You collect signal and
you den noiseise it. You refine it and
in the end you classify it and present
it to the human. So this is the overall
pipeline. We started with static
analysis. That's the traditional way of
doing it. Uh we use tools like coq and
yara. Uh then we can correlate those
things and fit it to the next stage. The
next stage is what we call the L1
triage. This is the D noiseis and refine
stage. This stage we're not making any
claims. We're not verifying anything.
We're we're just uh filing out the
obvious false positives. Um then the
next stage is what we call the L2 deep
verify. This is agentic. Uh we deploy it
into a isolated secure sandbox
environment. Uh it is equipped with PC
generation. This is this step is where
we actually slow down and get serious.
we um turn a maybe into a clear yes or
no with evidence. And in the end as
human loop as many of the great speakers
have mentioned we really want to keep
human in the loop and fer is designed to
not replace human researchers but to be
a force multiplier.
>> So when we first conceptualized this
system there was a lot of academic
research that was going around showing
how LLMs can complement traditional
static analysis. Uh so we looked at a
lot of those research papers um and it
was pretty interesting because through
our system we were able to confirm those
research papers and then research papers
later on actually demonstrated that you
know we were on the right track. Um so
the research papers we focused on were
false positive reduction. So getting rid
of the noise we don't want to overwhelm
human analysts. Um LLMs if you give it
an entire repo will feed you back tons
of noise but most of those signals are
not vulnerabilities. Um the other thing
was the discovery and deep analysis. Uh
and then the cost component. Uh so when
we first designed this system uh context
cost as well as LLM tool call cost uh
was taken into consideration here.
So this is another angle of what we're
trying to accomplish with this system.
So we take repos and then we eliminate
most of the false positives with a
cascade architecture. So we use all of
the uh traditional static analysis tools
and those also exist in a cascade as
well. So Yara is very good I don't uh in
the sense that it can scan millions of
lines of code in a matter of seconds. Uh
so we use that to find a bunch of minute
signals and then we filter out the
candidates through semrap and code and
that drops down the the number of
findings. So we eliminate most false
positives before it ever reaches an LLM
for triage.
Once the LLM the fast LLM uh triages it
might drop those further down uh which
go to the deep verify so L2 which is our
deep agentic triage uh and then it might
refine it down and then give about 90%
uh of those are actually true
vulnerabilities and give it over to the
human for bug bounty disclosure.
So, one thing to consider too is is when
we first conceptualized the system
around early 2025,
um that was really when the early
reasoning models started to make public
appearance. Uh context was pretty scant.
MCP servers had just been released a few
months ago. Uh Fender actually started
as a MCP server component and I think
MCP is a natural transition from uh tool
calling to actually building your own
agents.
So around March 2025 is uh when the
first concept of fenrer uh came into be.
We had some constraints. Uh one was
context efficiency. So we found that
using static analysis tools made the
whole context efficiency component very
precise. We were able to feed the right
context to the LLMs. Uh using
traditional tools. I think everyone's
has experience maybe giving a entire
repo to an LLM and trying it to say just
find vulnerabilities that doesn't work.
So later into the year last year is when
the first production scale um
advanced agents entered production.
[snorts]
So this is we're starting to see more um
advanced reasoning capabilities in cyber
security. Context windows are starting
to expand past a million tokens. I think
Gemini was the first um LLM that had a 1
million token context window
and then the next frontier. So we we can
we predict that the context window is
going to continue expanding and it's
pretty impressive that this fenure
system has survived many um generations
of LLMs.
>> Um thank you. Um before we continue, I
would like to start a demo right now.
So this is our this is a local demo for
our platform. Uh we're just going to
start a scan on the on on this
repository and after 10 minutes we will
check back on it and to see what what we
find. It should be should be
interesting.
All right. So continue the presentation.
Oh, sorry. uh as I have mentioned the
first step is static analysis. Well,
this is really a tool chain. We use four
different SAS tools uh each for a
different class of signal. Uh we start
with Yara X. We used this before to find
real vulnerabilities in the wild before.
It's really our fastest pref filter. And
then we move to SAM grip which is much
more precise and accurate than our X. Uh
it's even better if you have a large
rule set. Next we move to CQL. uh it
does data flow analysis 10 analysis is
much more heavy than YRL or SE grip but
we tend to get really good t uh true
positive case conversion out of it and
then finally spot box or fine sec box is
that's the extension we use that to deal
with Java binaries when we when we need
to so this is really a cascade we what
we want to do is a quick elimination up
front deep analysis later since it will
require more compute And since we're
using multiple SAS tools, two
correlation is not only uh natural, it's
logical. Uh if different tools point to
the same CWE class approximately the
same location for some plus minus 15
lines of code, well that's clear signal
that uh that's clear signal that's
confidence for us and that is more
importantly context for the later
stages. Uh at this stage we're not
spending a single dime on our um tokens.
Everything is done in the traditional
way. uh to collect signal.
All right, moving on to the next stage
where we call the L1 triage. Um so this
is where the fun begins because we
actually involve uh dealing with LLMs.
Here we use a fast but capable model uh
with pre-allocated static context. Uh in
our case uh it's 50 lines of code uh to
judge if uh the finding is clearly a
false positive. Uh the goal here is not
again is not to verify it's just to
reduce the noise. Uh we use CW specific
prompt. Uh so instead of asking it is
this false positive we ask is can this
possibly be CW79. Uh that gives it a
much narrow narrower target and that
performs better. Uh this is is also
biased towards recall. So it's fine to
let a few false positives go. What we
cannot accept is this stage dropping
true positives
and um the number here I think really um
explains why we are doing this over 60%
of findings is being filtered out by a
single son call instead of going into
the next stage which is much more
heavier involves multi- uh multi-turn
tool calling uh and the operational
impact is massive we have we're seeing a
big reduction in cost and throughput um
50 lines of code instead of 12 turns of
opus that is really a no-brainer. Um
some lessons model resing model resizing
is key. We tried queen 3 0.6B. We saw
okay well what is quick it should be a
class fair absolutely didn't work. It's
constantly drawing true positives and is
not working. Uh moving on to opus. Well
opus will work but that's kind of a
waste of resources. Not to mention it's
slower than son. So that limits
throughput. Uh and as always specific
prompting works better than generic
ones. After uh through our evaluation
harness we can confirm that this L1
triage has not dropped a single case
that would have been classified as true
positive by our L2 deep agentic triager
and this stage is has deliberate
asymmetry. This is not again I'm seeing
this the third time is not to make any
decisions is just to prune false
positives.
Okay. So this is uh where the meat is.
This is the most expens expensive stage.
There are all to a deep uh agentic
triage. Uh here we are using agent plus
isolated secure sandbox. Uh we get we're
using opus because we want the best
security domain knowledge. We want the
best reasoning capabilities and agentic
capabilities. So that that is for
example function calling. Uh and we're
providing it with full code context. We
are deploying it dropping it straight
into a isolated secure sandbox uh with
full execution full write uh privilege.
It can write uh run bash it can write a
Python script and then executed with
bash whatever it needs to do uh we let
it do it. Um and we also have a built-in
multi-step reasoning and built-in
reflection to keep the model honest.
Sometimes what we are observing is the
model kind of cheat. They they do a
really shallow reasoning and just call
it a day. But this built-in reflection
really reduces that because it has to
fight itself on proving this is not a
false positive.
So while this stage cost you um we're
seeing a a median of 61 cents per
finding. Uh that's around 100,000 tokens
in consumption. Uh this this can easily
scale to uh over 1 million with complex
cases. For example, multi file data flow
cases in a really really large
repository. Uh and if we are just
looking at the true positives that is
around $8.80 per true positives is not
cheap but is much much more affordable
than the traditional way of doing it. Um
again some lessons and uh we learned
force reflection really helped
hallucination has always been a
challenge in AI and some some way of
reducing that really helps in a
production system. Uh reachability first
triage is key. A if that code is not
interesting a documentation a test case
uh no reach code that's not reachable is
not interesting from a vulnerability
hunt perspective. So we filter that out
immediately. And since the agents now
are super good that they are intelligent
they know domain knowledge we can just
let it roam. We can um just ask it and
let it collect context on its own. A
knows what more context it needs. A
knows how to uh trace data flow. It
knows how to use cograph tools to build
a call graph. Just let it roam. We don't
need to pre-allocate context. And
finally, human in the loop. Um so human
is still involved in this but their
workflow is greatly simplified. Uh we're
reducing from 500 stats alerts from just
10 to 20 high confident ones. uh each
with autogenerated vulnerability report
recalls impact etc with a crafty park uh
and the full disclosure package. So the
human can just verify, validate, verify
exploitability, review severity, and
submit to the vendor.
And since thin rare has been deploying
to production, we're seeing a 2.5 times
in more vulnerability discovered with
80% less false positive false positive
rate. And not to mention, we're also
seeing 70% more dis uh faster disclosure
rate at overall three times increase in
team productivity. Um well from 500 raw
findings to 250 post L1 to the final 10
to 25 Hong confidence two true positive
findings uh we have submitted over 60
CVEes and counting there's still over
100 in ZDI predisclosure and 3,000
that's pending review
>> yeah and those are all CVEEs that are
high or critical we don't really waste
our time with the the medium level
severities uh we can use the other uh
like script kitties to find those so
we're looking for uh meaningful security
impact.
So what makes this system unique? So the
multiscanner correlation algorithm. So
the cascading of the uh the triage
process. Our kill chain analysis system.
So we do exploit path modeling uh to
find risky attack surface faster. Uh the
weighted context generation. So we have
an algorithm in there that intelligently
uh dynamically allocates tokens. So
tokens are allocated to different parts
intelligently and not just static across
the entire analysis. Uh the dynamic
priority scoring engine. So we have a
scoring engine that surfaces the most
severe and most critical uh
vulnerabilities for immediate
disclosure.
Um
yeah I already went over the multi-
vendor AI. So that that's another thing
actually. So when we built this system
there's there's a lot of focus on old
code. So looking at different projects
that have a a foothold in the industry,
we pointed this system at the AI
ecosystem itself. So we're using AI to
secure AI because the attack surface for
AI components is absolutely massive.
So into the future, uh this goes along
with the int uh advanced capabilities of
some of the latest foundational models.
uh we're able to do adversarial
interrogation, for example. We're able
to do memory corruption bugs more
efficiently. At first, we didn't even
start with the memory corruption because
of the context window sizes and we
really wanted to nail down the uh
pipeline itself. But now with the more
advanced capabilities of mo opus 4.6 for
example, we're able to use the LLM as an
adversarial component.
So we also have bigger goals. So we were
doing mostly open source repositories
but now we're going to do uh
vulnerability discovery across
organizational levels. Uh that gives an
interesting perspective because
organizations sometimes have their own
interesting quirks. They might have
their own interesting security
boundaries. So being able to scale
across an entire organization uh is
critical.
So yeah, as we uh as we're up here
talking, we just got an alert that one
of our uh CVS in Langchain got patched.
So as we're talking, we're Vener is
doing work for us.
>> Thank you.
>> Do we have audience questions? While
we're uh while we're looking for
audience questions, I'll I'll take one
from one from the Slack, which is uh
have you ever done like any
retrospective analysis to see if true
positives might be filtered out uh
earlier in the earlier in the pipeline.
>> Yeah, we do a reinforcement of of some
of the static analysis uh rule sets and
some of the previous runs. We keep a
record of all the runs. Everything that
you do with an LLM, we keep as potential
future context that we can use to
improve the system uh and do some
metrics and some testing.
>> Um excuse me. Can can we uh have our
screen up because we have to do Yes. The
demo.
>> Yeah. We just want to show uh our
console. Uh
>> yeah. So this is
>> exactly. So this is the one we just
started uh is on AON UI. Uh a static
analysis found 122 findings. Our one
filtered out 37. This one is actually
not performing that well. Uh but what's
important is that it found 21 true
positives and
we have all the information redacted. So
we're not uh leaking any sensitive
information but uh what it is is that is
a for example a pass driver. So
vulnerability has specific lines and
with specific reasoning u what's the
counter argument what's the
recommendation what's the impact and the
whole system is set up in a way to
maximize both pre um human so that's the
scanning part and post human we want to
maximize throughput. Yes. So yeah, and
we also have a window so you can
actually talk to the LLM triager. So you
can treat the the LLM as a security
researcher colleague and bounce ideas
off, try to explain the the
vulnerability. Uh, one thing that we've
actually um found very useful in pruning
false positives is a actually having
another LLM ask or try to disprove that
this is a vulnerability. So kind kind of
like at a bug bounty program where
you're uh scrutinizing a researcher's
finding. You're trying to find why this
isn't a vulnerability.
>> One over there, I think.
>> Hi. Yeah, I had a question. So, you
discussed how uh the different
generations of models have improved and
uh now with Opus, you're able to find a
lot more stuff and you're also having to
manage context. And I was wondering if
you've experimented at all with the
different thinking levels for the models
because I've done some similar work and
uh I haven't dug really far into the
different thinking levels and trade-offs
with that.
So, we didn't really need to to to go
there with this system. Um, this system
was pre was built when all of that um
didn't exist. So, the architecture is
starting to change. So, um that will
definitely be a consideration in Fener
2.0.
>> Yeah. And uh with this system that's
live, uh we're just using high high
async level. Yes.
>> Thank you.
>> Got one more time for one more up front
here.
Thanks Jason.
I'm
>> just wondering like if you could talk I
don't know how much you can about like
the confidence score like it says
medium. So what does like a medium mean
as opposed to a low? I'm just so that's
some secret sauce on how we score
confidence levels at the LLM triage
level. So the human will probably see
that that's a medium confidence. Ask
why. You can talk with the the agent
itself and figure that out. It's a
dynamic scoring system that we have.
Yes.
>> Thank you very much.